Christopher this is the biggest win of
your career how do you feel you just
took down the defending U.S Champion
with the black pieces
I feel like it's a great Redemption from
yesterday
especially after after seeing their
interview and everything I felt like I
was kind of disrespected and it was also
kind of a wake-up call that I really
needed to improve my openings and
everything
how did you feel after that game
yesterday because you had your chances
as well right and there's some rivalry
between you and Hans it seals I felt
disrespected on every level
why is that why did you take it
personally I guess because after after
the like after the interview and
everything
just because he said the game spoke for
itself yeah
and you definitely came with a very
combative mindset into today's game take
us through the key I I did feel like I
channeled in a little bit of my anger
from that to play some aggressive chess
today and that's great if you can
channel the anger and use it to your
advantage that's absolutely a good thing
take us through the game Christopher
oh by the way you started with a Russian
how did you come up with that idea
I I just I I wanted to play like an
actual good opening not try to be on
sound just be as solid as possible makes
uh sense if you want to be solid
definitely will pick the Petrov but he
did win he has quite good results
against the Petrov he just beat Fabiano
caruana in the same field cup you know
Petrov or are you aware of that were you
afraid of that at any point
I actually didn't know this time
I only saw the game Fabiano beat him in
the Petra from three months ago I wasn't
aware of the same field Cup game okay
okay yeah and I think that one actually
he deviated quite early on after 94 he
played Bishop to D3 completely different
game now
when were you out of the opening out of
your book let's say
maybe around move 50 15 yes I prepared
it up to this bishop G6 F5
very nice idea F5 and I tweet when you
were also building a nice time advantage
on the clock and this became crucial to
your strategy as you guys were entering
the final stages of the game were you
thinking already about putting as much
pressure on his time as possible at that
point
I wasn't sinking much because I was
moving fast I guess
I'm I I don't know not not in particular
I think it was I think it was more like
it was a difficult position for him to
play but I wasn't really playing for his
time and
did you feel any nerves coming from his
side
because you were he was probably nervous
but of course I can't read into his mind
so I really don't know how nervous he
was but
um
I wouldn't expect him to be a little bit
nervous
um
since I was kind of attacking him yes
one thing that struck us is he was
always ready to write something on his
piece of paper did you notice that as
well it was kind of giving me flashbacks
to what happened to him in like the 2015
U.S championship against where he kept
writing these notes like to himself and
then he got like disqualified but
um those were the flashbacks that we
were getting out yes
but it didn't even if he was writing
something it didn't seem to help today
absolutely and uh let's go further into
the game F3 Queen to H4 very nicely
timed Rook to H6 and right now probably
his best chance was to take on e4 did
you spot this move and how did you
assess the position after Knight takes
E4 I thought it might have been like a
repetition with takes on e4 Bishop takes
E4 Queen takes H2 King F1 Queen H1 check
oh never mind I I kind of missed that he
got sacked this G2 Punk between two and
King D3 yeah
yeah and this seems to be due to the
fact that he's coming with D5 or B5 your
pieces are a bit strangely placed on the
queen side it seems to be better for him
but he didn't do it he played the H3
which is a very natural move to make of
course Knight to G5 and at this point it
already felt like you're taking over the
initiative especially due to the fact
that he only had 13 minutes a new 39 and
you were playing fast at this point
um when was the critical moment this was
a big one how did you come up to the
conclusion that you have to sacrifice
what about Queen H3 it was actually more
of an intuitive decision I just felt
like there had to be some huge attack
after and I didn't calculate it that
deeply
um I just I just had the feeling and I
almost kind of missed that he had this
queen G2 Rook F2 defense and then that
he was kind of Defending everything and
I kind of got lucky that I still had
resources after that and just to show
you a nice idea Anastasia just mentioned
uh instead of Knight to D 7 I think it
was this point after root 2 E2 no not
this one instead of Bishop to d8 I think
you had this move
Queen takes H3 I actually saw it
um I I didn't want to play this end game
after Knight H3 King F1 Knight F2 King
F2 Rook H2 King F1 Rook B2 Rook E7
and I saw that it had it was like some
draw with Rick F7 rookie River Cafe yes
oh I guess Bishop takes H7 yeah Bishop
H7 zero F7 doesn't work
you have to go Bishop to A5 and indeed
he has some compensation in the position
it was just a nice line that we wanted
to show you uh and you did decide to go
sacrifice on H3
and now you repeat it once
and you got down to your last two
minutes
how did you come up with the conclusion
that yes it's time to take some chances
it's time to play Rook E8 and try to
play for a win this one
because you have to draw in the back
again it's one of the best chess players
in the world
I sort of yeah I think I I spent most of
my 30 minutes saying just trying to
calculate as deeply as possible and I
didn't see anything wrong while I was
calculating so I just went for it I just
had to trust myself absolutely and you
made the right decision Rook 28 putting
a lot of pressure and this was a big one
did you even look at this bishop takes
A5 idea I didn't but the next move I
actually realized it and I was like oh
[ __ ] this is that that was that was kind
of a big Miss so it was but I still had
to like psychologically recover from
that and you could still do it right
yeah but here I here I wasn't as
convinced for some reason
um and you were getting down to your
last few minutes last minute actually in
fact at this point I think I might have
actually missed it again I think I just
kept missing it while I was low on time
so you played Knight F6 Bishop to E1 and
after that you just played a pretty much
perfect game I have to say Bishop to C7
a great move Rook to B3 is the only way
to keep the balance in the position for
him but it's not huge well I'm actually
curious how does that keep because yeah
yes yes and you actually sacrifice a
piece after Queen takes G5 they take
here Knightley to Queen B3 and queen F5
is supposedly a draw wow that's insane
it is it is and not human Wesley is not
nobody's going to find this uh he played
rookie seven
and you finished him off in style
Christopher a huge Victory
congratulations guys any questions for
our victim absolutely uh first of all
Christopher congratulations and also uh
you when you burned your clock playing
the move rookie eight and the screwed
the Perpetual repetition
um
you you must have been having this inner
struggle like I gotta play on I gotta
play on and you're calculating uh when
you got down so low on time that was
exactly the point that I was about to
say no he's going to take the Perpetual
because you're so low on time but you
went for it uh what was it that gave you
that courage
hmm I I I I I felt like there had to be
something
I didn't I I for some reason like my
position looked way too active for there
not to be something so it was also kind
of based on feeling at the end of the
day but I did try to calculate it as
well as possible before doing it well
once again congratulations you made the
Bold decision and it paid off well done
good luck in the rest of the event thank
you cheers
and we have one